I'm not buying a pair of shoes or a
dress unless Gideon says yes anyway we
went shopping and he's like there
standing up straight you know by my side
and the women in the shop kept coming
over to me and they were asking me like
are you okay do you need any help
because they were worried that like I
had like a pimp next to me or something
or like some toxic man next to me being
like evil and demanding and telling me
what to wear and I'm like yeah I'm fine
and they just kept circulating to see if
like I was safe and it's like no that's
my brother he's a Manny Man and I want
his opinion on what I'm wearing so I'm
gonna so yes he's standing outside the
dressing room not to control me but to
directly and make sure that I pick a
nice dress